thulliez j'accueille patrick devedjian
je vais pas vous torturer avec la
assurez-vous un bon c'est pas est ce que
c'était a ouais c'était par rouen 67
liste à rouen 76 non non bon il s'était
avancé alors que c'est tout vous pensez
vous dit finalement bon il ya murat il
est sympa on va pas se disputer à la
télé tout mais pour corser un peu la
faire j'ai demandé à mon ami landes
affiche anti parlant ça va très bien on
n'a pas annoncé pourquoi je t'ai pas
annoncé parce que je voulais faire la
surprise à patrick devedjian qu'on
apparition complètement battant contents
que je sois là mais tout à fait que j'ai
besoin de quelqu'un pour rebondir
comment ça va ça va très bien cette fois
ci je sais tout tu sais tu donc par
exemple est ce que tu sais que patrick
n'a jamais publié un livre s'appelle
penser la droite je les lui ils seraient
les gens de penser la droite
voilà bien écrit et beaucoup de style
j'ai passé un bon moment je les connais
ça marche parce que je ne reconnaissais
plus ma fille refrain si pas
l'adversaire s'appelle delevoye vous
intéresser à face à berne armand oui oui
mais voilà il ya devedjian manas vers
certains concurrents voilà concurrents
il ya alliot marie il ya bulté qui est
hyper aux maoïstes
c'était intéressant comme un personnage
un oeil amusé ou pas car celui-ci est
urgent que maintenant
pardon il est gentil et sympathique mais
c'est devenu notre copain muzeau a dit
on a un copain mars arrive maintenant à
une sympa mais quand on va à marseille
mais ils ont dors chez toi même bon
alors delevoye lui il est soutenu il est
aidé par pandraud dépendront pour vous
c'est tout ce qu'il faut plus faire
prendre aux ponts-de-cé la vieille-gare
quoi c'est une image un peu ancien du
rpr oui en moi je préfère avoir une
image plus moderne
je viens [ __ ] difficile bah c'est pas
dire déjà vous donner beaucoup de mal
tout seul mais c'est vrai que quand on
en rajoute encore des cadavres
bon et puis en plus de le voir votre
concurrent est pas votre adversaire
il est sénateur parce qu'il n'a pas été
mieux législatives et lui les sénateurs
il est peinard et pendant ce temps vous
vous colle t l'assemblée nationale avec
jose pas un petit peu bref c'est un
petit pas est ce que c'est un petit peu
vrai par exemple qui a longtemps que le
rpr a pas gagné une ville dans le pas de
calais ça c'est un constat
c'est un constat ils s'adorent c'est un
bonheur aïssa d'or c'est un bonheur ça
n'a rien de leur père
tous les sens
oh là là alors et ambiante le scrutin et
sur deux tours en principe et delevoye
il s'inquiète de qui va s'occuper des
urnes pendant la nuit du 1er jour de
votre main tenant il ya il sait sur un
seul jour justement à supprimer le
deuxième jour ils ont confiance est
d'accord oui vous vous êtes dit
finalement si on fait tout en chantier
sur deux jours dans la nuit je vais
mourir
jusque là nous avions des candidats
uniques oui alors ça posait pas beaucoup
de problèmes et pour la première fois il
ya une vraie concurrence est vrai et
c'est plutôt bien
ouais alors ça suppose de prendre plus
de plus de précautions et vous savez
quand on fait des élections normales
dans le pays aussi on prend des
précautions pourquoi on les prendrait
panneaux vous pensez pas qu'on ait
l'impression qu'à droite finalement ils
sont plus préoccupés de ce tir et les
baux entre que vous voyez le pack de
batteries envers là je pense qu'ils sont
dans une situation que la gauche est
connu dans d'autres périodes donc je
pense que l'histoire l'histoire tourne
mais je crois qu'ils sont vraiment dans
dans la nasse et que là vous êtes dans
un piège pour pas mal d'années je crois
je ne crois pas parce que moi je crois
que la démocratie c'est une potion
magique et jusqu'à maintenant nous avons
souffert d'une insuffisance attendait
encore déception mais on se rattrape
lundi non vous avez tous vous
politiquement parce que c'est mal
patrick devedjan réalité on va en parler
mais restait très violemment anti
communiste en dur et serré anti
stalinien
vous avez déclaré mme bouvier aucune
différence entre l'allemagne nazie la
russie soviétique
oui et que je manie avec les cadres du
pc aujourd'hui en france c'est
exactement pareil que les apparatchiks
du à la cèze vous qui avez été j'ai été
trotskiste vous vous avez été au pc dans
le sens inverse d'abord mon pc après
trois fils mais oui et alors quand vous
entendez ce parcours tout à fait
conventionnelle je suis je vais finir
leurs vieux social-démocrate consensuel
mais je n'ai rien renier de ce qui a
fondé
ma pensée quand j'avais 18 ans lorsque
l'algérie c'est très vous n'êtes ni en
algérie ni la famille de votre mère
était algérie française par une partie
voilà mais vous vous êtes élevées contre
ce en fait je ne perds et emin désiste
voilà retard était mon assistant que
c'est finalement on était très ivre est
de faire l'indépendance de la tunisie
donc finalement vous êtes élevé contre
ça vous est utile pour l'algérie
indépendante
et vous alors ce qui vous a décidé à
entrer en politique c'est justement 60
heures à condorcet l'algérie vous pensez
que l'algérie vais rester française
absolument je pensais ça je pensais ça
parce que je suis aussi d'une famille
immigrée familles chrétiennes d'orient
et qui a vu sa liberté se réduire qui a
vu un génocide perpétré à l'encontre de
ce qui est et qui constitue en minorité
vous êtes d'origine va vous habitez à
votre famille habitait constantinois
parce que monsieur devedjian ne dit
jamais istanbul 1 c'est constantinople
donc il a ses têtes de dur quand même il
a situé au dessus donc monsieur
devedjian votre famille vient de
constantinople 1 et mais je pars
maignien donc vous dit que vous aviez
français oui la cabra d'origine
arménienne comme voyez méric vous
pleurez oui conviés à ce niveau vous dit
bonjour voila l arménien donc vous avez
vous vous avez vu ce pouvoir confisqué
j'ai vu la montée de l'islam intolérante
j'ai vu ce qu'a été le nationalisme turc
ravagée justement la différence empêcher
les minorités d'exister et les supprimer
physiquement la guerre d'algérie c'était
pas la montée lis je me suis défoncé et
comment la vente est d'islamiser bien
écouter ça a été ça en définitive ouais
je faire ample raconté tuncer vous on
prend sur 30 ans pas sur dix ans la
guerre d'algérie c'est pas une guerre
est une guerre d'un deal à l'immense
coloniale oui c'est pas est la montée du
jeu la mise je suis les frères musulmans
soient venus après longtemps après mais
ils n'entendent et c'est une autre
histoire c'est l'histoire d'une nation
qui s'appelle la nation algérienne c'est
plus l'histoire de l'amérique française
de l'algérie algérienne théoriquement
vous avez parfaitement raison je me suis
trompé si c'est ce que vous voulez me
faire dire je vous le mets voile en
tirant aussi bien certaine manière mais
lee volontiers comme disait nisand un
qui est plus proche de vous j'avais 20
ans et je ne laisserai personne dire que
c'est le plus bel âge de la vie
mais donc je me suis trompé sur
l'algérie mais il n'empêche sur d'autres
choses mais oui mais bien sûr l'histoire
d'une vie celle ayant beaucoup d'erreurs
un bien alors si vous êtes élu grandes
idées politiques en fait patrick
devedjian s'il est élu patron du rpr
donc c'est de refaire l'alliance c'est à
dire de faire un grand parti unique de
l'opposition c'est votre avis un bon
outil mais c'est une de mes idées mais
ça m'a dérangé des données sap a marché
la première fois pourquoi vouloir
recommencer je veux dire que ça c'est
incontournable toute façon c'est pas
suffisant
c'est le nécessaire mais ce n'est pas le
suffisant ma grande idée c'est de
moderniser le rpr c'est d'en faire un
parti qui soit en phase avec la société
avec le monde tel qu'il est devenu
c'est vrai que c'est drôle ça moderniser
leurs
euh tu t'es trompé de touche je voulais
mettre quoi je vais mettre autre chose
avec votre campagne est un peu
désordonné on dit elle est un peu un peu
amateur pour quoi faire j'ai pas
beaucoup d'argent
certainement j'ai pas beaucoup d'art
parce que je revenais je n'ai que la
force de mes convictions c'est déjà pas
mal j'ai beaucoup je disais l'autre jour
on peut changer le monde avec ses
convictions et oui je lisais l'autre
jour que vous étiez dans une voiture qui
a été emmenés à la fourrière dit y aller
dans le nord ça arrive à tous les
français vous êtes quand même un député
il a tort
moi je cherche bleus étaient périmés oui
vous avez plus de scènes du jeu les
charges et non la connais glee gens vous
êtes tombé en panne d'essence lanto et
faheem sais pas mais ça part en couille
la drogue des choses arrive à tout le
monde c'est vrai on a un truc dans ma
troyer tellement que les députés vivent
dans un univers protégé ben là vous
découvrez un extrait la question carte
bleue et panne d'essence on pense pas où
ses protégés c'est pour autre chose
qu'on pense grand rodez pour l'heureux
en 97 le rpr a reçu 230 5 millions de
francs alors vous qui vous marque
personnes vous qui vouliez pas de
subventionner qu'il est ou le pognon là
d'abord on paye un loyer qui est très
chef de centre ces 215 millions jeudi
pour ma mère maman ça fait quoi 23
milliards de centimes a quand même mais
non pas toute nouvelle boutique pendule
loyers le loyer non il n'ya pas que le
loyer mais faire vivre un milliard
brille ça coûte cher
faire vivre un grand partisan
m'attendais v où il peut donc quand vous
faites votre élection vous donne quand
même une allocation là pour votre
élection chaque la wii la wii nous
allons avoir cent trente mille francs
chacun cent trente mille francs chacun
seulement
mais elle est où la différence la
différence d'abord le rpr c'est aussi
une centaine de personnes qui
travaillent pour lui qu'il faut payer à
coup de fraîcheur je vous adore d'en
face où les 235 me retrouver les bras
samedi je vous avion c'est pas bon signe
non mais attendez
tu trouves pas ça louche toi non c'est
malheureusement pas lucho ne peut-être
bien toujours bien dépensé tourner de
bord
c'est vite parti croyez moi c'est vite
parti au patent avec donc certaines
personnes ne sont 35 millions us en 39
ans ils sont six a fait un truc disant
900 mille balles tous les partis sont
dans cette situation
bon c'est la démocratie c'est normal
c'est la république je suis rien et
qu'on leur donne et lui remettant des
droits humains parce que je veux dire
les normes ce et elle se voit les danses
urbaines d'essence avec le blé que tu
apprécies tu aurais pu quand même tu
confonds iqbal khan il vous mesurer
combien 1 m 77 à ça tombe bien c'est ce
qu'il a dit chirac à sarkozy un et je le
vois lui valent c'est un peu son
candidat chirac un delevoye et où c'est
pourquoi parce qu'il mesure 1 mètre 90
ça c'est important
il même un peu plus je crois même un peu
plus fait 77 et que je suis un peu juste
en tarif mois mais il ne le voyais plus
haut il n'y a pas de doute
ouais murat aurait jamais pu être
président du rpr par l'envers on peut
savoir pourquoi vous avez voté contre le
pacs ah oui facilement
j'ai voté contre le pacs parce que le
remède est pire que le mal
j'ai voté contre le pac malema
malheureux maintenant c'est un jeu de
mots facile et je veux les chars datant
de juin difficile ça peut être
ouais plus subtile aussi - y bon je vais
répondre à la question si un gros lot on
a entendu
j'ai voté contre le pacs parce qu'il
institue une discrimination nouvelle
pour bénéficier de nouveaux droits pour
un homosexuel il faut se déclarer et
être inscrits sur un registre
accessibles au public et moi je pense
que la pratique sexuelle ça appartient à
la vie privée et qu'on ne doit pas être
obligé de la révéler pour bénéficier de
ses droits
c'est bête je ne vois pas comment on
peut être contre le fait qu' abandonner
des personnes librement qui veulent
s'associer et n'iront se déclarer à la
mairie que ceux qui voudront c'est pas
obligatoire quand vous parlez de
fichiers c'est un rapt historique de 7
comme expression parce qu'on voit très
bien à quoi ça fait allusion
donc c'est irrecevable dire comment
donné il va y avoir un fichier les
homosexuels non il ya un fichier de ceux
qui voudront un moment donné est pacsé
mais ceux qui n'ont pas envie c'est pas
leurs pratiques sexuelles qui va
abandonner les dénoncer s'ils vont pas
s'inscrire
ça ne valait rien non mais et en plus
vous réduisez d'abord le pacs à
l'homosexualité ce qui est pâle ce qui
est pas la réalité parce que c'est pas
que les homosexuels et deuxièmement vous
réduisez en parlant de l'homosexualité
l'homosexualité une pratique sexuelle
mais c'est faux il ya il ya une culture
homosexuelle existe à tout abandon qu'on
peut pas réduire sa la pratique sexuelle
dans c'est pas simplement de savoir
comment les gens font l'amour qui valait
déterminé socialement donc il me semble
que comme sur l'europe moi j'ai voté
pour maastricht
vous aussi on l'était certainement pas
d'accord sur le texte il ya des tas de
choses qui sont imparfaites mais un
moment donné faut bien passer à une
étape supérieure
donc c'est comme sur l'avortement c'est
toujours l'arrière-garde il ya toujours
vous c'est pour ça que en fin de compte
la droite reste ce qu'elle est et que
vous avez quand même pas rompu avec vos
origines
c'était un moment je parle politique je
dis qu'il ya un moment donné ça j'ai pas
c'est un combat d'arrière garde
mais pas du tout je suis en train de
vous expliquer actuellement les
homosexuels qui par exemple vivent en
concubinage subissent une discrimination
inacceptable
il faut mettre un remède à cette
situation je suis d'accord la situation
actuelle n'est pas bonne le remède
proposé par les socialistes c'est que
les gens qui ne voudront plus subir
cette discrimination se déclare par le
pacs au tribunal d'instance sur un
registre accessible à tout le monde et
qui permettra de savoir quels sont les
moeurs qu'ils ont choisie en moi je dis
cette chose on a le droit
on a le droit d'être homosexuel sans
avoir besoin de le déclarer publiquement
et je suis dos
pour la protection du secret de la
timidité maintenant un d'accord marche
intellectuelle et président assassin
c'est une démarche qui part quand même
de la notion du bien et du mal
c'est giroud votre raisonnement il part
de là bernard murat bernard murat disait
patrick devedjian l instant finalement
vous n'avez pas tellement renier vos
origines alors politique politique
d'assurer ce printemps ont fait pas
gentil non sélection de là mais c'est la
goutte et qu'il a été trotskiste quand
il est jeune
j'ai été d'extrême droite voilà bon il
ya 30 ans qui sont passés c'est une
vieille guerre civile et dites moi le
front national en 92 avait déclaré tant
que le front national est légal il est
légalisée qui touche déjà ces fameux 40
millions par an de l'état tant que le
front national est légal vous avez dit
ça dans le figaro c'est normal qu'ils
puissent se réunir et vous trouviez
anormal à l'époque donc en 92 que
certaines mairies interdisent au front
national de se réunir dans des salles
municipales
en 98 vous dites le front national n'est
pas un parti républicain vous avez quand
même changé donc pas du tout aussi
complètement national n'est pas un parti
républicain je souhaite son interdiction
pure et simple
oui dans le monde alors je vous pose une
question vous après vous répondrai est
ce que vous en faites pas un peu trop
pour faire oublier votre passé non je
vous explique très simplement moi j'ai
été d'extrême droite je sais pourquoi je
suis obligé de prendre des positions
mais je vous expliquais j'ai été
descendre jusqu'en 1966 en 1966 j'ai
rencontré raymond aron et c'est lui qui
a fait de moi un démocrate
quant au front national je suis le
premier maire de droite
le premier en france à voir retirer sa
délégation and ses adjoints parce qu'il
était passé au front national donc j'ai
pas de leçons à recevoir
je dis simplement il faut être cohérent
si le front national est considérée
comme légale par les autorités de la
république
alors il a le droit à toutes les
libertés prévu par la république y
compris la liberté de réunion
ouais en revanche si on veut lui dénier
le droit de se réunir à peut-être
faut-il considérer que c'est parce qu'il
n'est pas en réalité réellement
républicain et qu'il n'est équipe dans
ce cas là il doit être interdit
revin ses mains